this might sound mad but I work Less
hours now than I did when I first
started I get into Works a little bit
after eight and I'm Gone by six all I
focus on is on high value business and
generating the most Revenue I will not
waste time in what I consider a bad
business and I'm not just talking about
you know Revenue exactly I'm talking
about what's my competition how many
other agencies work in this role how
good is my relationship with the hiring
manager how well do I know this client
what's the candidate Network there's a
lot of variables that go into what I
consider good business and bad business
but I think that's a trait of a lot of
high performers I speak to they can turn
around and say no